bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo blog e io sono favi dei ho
deciso di fare questo blog veloce veloce
durerà poco pochissimi minuti poi magari
guardate sotto c'è scritto 29 durerà
pochissimo perché voglio soltanto
rispondere a delle vostre domande che mi
avete chiesto air innanzi tutto vi
ringrazio perché diciamo i miei video
stanno avendo abbastanza visualizzazioni
miei progetti stanno piacendo e volevo
farvi sapere che finora avete visto per
gli mente quasi solo video hard perché
ero stato un po assente dalle scene
gaming da quando creato fa vige tv e in
molti mi avete chiesto vidor e niente
quindi mi sono concentrato ball più su
questa su questo genere di video ecco ma
sappiate che questo canale non è
soltanto concentrato sugli horror ma ci
sono anche videogames come che adesso vi
andrò alencar e non visto dire tutti qua
intanto il filo sto dando minchia non lo
faccio vedere perché sembra tipo avete
presente le bombe quando le disinnescate
tipo taglia il filo rosso
non vorrei che mi esplodessero le cuffie
vabbè comunque per l'argomento cuffie mi
avete detto che si sentono meglio io mi
fido di voi perché prima utilizzavo
utilizzavo sta roba qui che non è
considerata invece non solo non si
possono chiamare cuffie queste perché
veramente è un qualcosa di osceno
roba da 5 euro bancarelle tipo
e vabbè comunque vi ringrazio per i
commenti i buoni sulle cuffie perché
penso che adesso in avanti utilizzano
queste nei blog in genere dovrei
togliermi perché dato non devo sentire
niente però oggi o dei capelli più
arrendi del solito quindi non me ne
dolgo e vabbè per questa volta e così ho
deciso di comprare queste cuffie
innanzitutto per il fatto che a un amico
l'autopulizia dell'audio del microfono
quindi mi sentite un po meglio e poi
anche per questo
si illumina no vabbè sta roba qui
sarebbe perimeter dolby sorround quando
si gioca un videogame con dolby surround
ti sembra di essere ti sembra di
impersonare al cento per cento il
personaggio principale quindi negli
horror e più fa più effetto
sto utilizzando il video come specchio
perché se non trovo il tasto tanto il
filo sono di nuovo appuntamento
va beh per quanto riguarda invece i
videogame non horror che andrà a fare
perché ovviamente vi ripeto non è un
canale incentrato solo su gli horror tra
quelli che mi avete consigliato allora
happy with me l'avete consigliato in
tantissimi e farò qualche episodio penso
proprio di sì perché me l'avete chiesto
in tanti anche se lo fanno altri
youtubers comunque me l'avete chiesto e
quindi lo farò draw my thing e per chi
non lo conoscesse invece è una rubrica
che facevo sul psg è una rubrica che
facevo io e premete consiste nel
disegnare un qualcosa insieme è una
rubrica che si fa insieme a voi iscritti
a tutti quelli che hanno messo mi piace
alla pagina di facebook ci sara una
volta in cui scriverò ai ragazzi i primi
cinque che si connettono appariranno nel
prossimo video perché va di mente è un
videogame che faccio con voi ovviamente
consiste nel disegnare un qualcosa una
parola che viene data agli atti da
devono indovinare e quindi i primi 5 di
voi che partecipano che è praticamente
lo diro nella pagina facebook quindi se
volete partecipare mettete mi piace alla
pagina di facebook che trovate in ogni
video nella descrizione anche in questo
è niente droga infine lo farò sicuro
perché fa scappare da ridere
svendita bis svendita bis ultimamente me
lo state consigliando veramente in
tantissimi lo farò e ci siamo
organizzati io e tron bonne la faremo
insieme in coop
e quindi per slang ita b se faremo
qualche episodio insieme per quanto
riguarda invece la coop condivido che me
lo state chiedendo da da tipo quando
abbiamo fatto porta lio e di domi state
continuando a chiedere quand'è che
continuate la coop quand'è che ha fatto
una coop
allora ci siamo sentiti recentemente io
ed i do abbiamo deciso che faremo una
coop suo centro oltre appena avremo
tempo diciamo la faremo quindi niente
non continuato a chiesa ce l'ha perché
ormai ci siamo organizzati quindi state
tranquilli la coop ci sarà
tranquillissimo e la faremo insieme su
sei tra oltre è un videogame che hanno
già fatto ad ha fatto un bel po di gente
in coop
in pochi però hanno già fatto fare
insieme una coop su questo videogame io
e lui per il nostro modo di commentare
sarebbe fantastico e io concordo con lui
quindi draw my thing macché draw my
thing centro ove lo farò con dido appena
sarà possibile
altra roba che mi sono segnato qualora
c'è direi che me lo state consigliando
in tanti ed è sempre horror farò anche
questo perché ormai pur di non sentirvi
di non sentirlo consigliare più lo farò
però diciamo lido cercherò di
distribuire perché ovviamente non voglio
fare soltanto vidor
questo vale anche per sc p
che anche questo mi rete consigliate lo
farò e invece per amnesia 2 faceless
quando usciranno prova bale come si
chiamano mi ricordo più il workflow
quindi farò la storia praticamente tutta
dall'inizio alla fine amnesia due
ovviamente ancora non è uscita non ci ha
giocato ancora nessuno quindi tutto
inesplorato aveva aperto un recente
sondaggio sulla pagina di facebook dove
vi chiedevo se preferivate che facessi
episodi di penombra sempre lunghi sui 15
16 minuti oppure se raddoppiare la
lunghezza di 30 40 minuti
questo perché voglio cercare di finirlo
prima possibile perché molti poi mi
hanno detto che era più spaventoso di
penombra il secondo black flag
grazie per avermi corretto nella
pronuncia mentre invece mi avete trovato
tutti non è spaventoso ci sono dei cani
che alla lunga si sono spaventosi però a
un certo punto ti abitui e non è che
sono più spaventosi cerchi di
sopravvivere basta fin dove sono
arrivato io e poi non so se ci sono
sorpreso cosa del genere però nell'altro
penombra c'erano proprio i mostri quindi
era un po più diciamo spaventoso
comunque cercherò di finirlo in breve
facendo il viso di più lui così almeno
chi lo segue
si guarderà anche qui hai quegli episodi
e quindi niente per quanto riguarda
penombra cercherò di finirlo cioè non so
quanti episodi durerà ancora penso tre o
quattro per comunque se li faccio più
lunghi durerà meno quindi dei progetti
un po haven e ho parlato mi sono
ricordato che dovevo salutare chiara e
andrea che sono due ragazzi che mi hanno
riconosciuto nel senso mi hanno fermato
e ne ha detto ma sei fa vj tu si sono
fatti j
vi saluto quindi un saluto a chiara e
andrea se mi vedete per strada fermatemi
cecchina temi
niente ditevi vostro nome così vi saluto
non posso salutare tutti ovviamente su
youtube perché se non sareste tutti
quanti i miei scritti che mi chiedete di
salutarvi
però va bè incontrate lo farò di certo
comunque progetti un po degli oggetti
per quanto riguarda del grande di
youtube
ancora non mi è arrivata la partnership
con mascini ma dovrebbe arrivare mia
giorni proprio da un momento all'altro
anche mentre sto facendo questo video
potrebbe essermi è arrivata adesso vado
a vedere adesso magari vedo in diretta
c'è un nuovo iscritto ma niente partner
vabbè comunque dovrebbe arrivare proprio
momenti già visti giorni qui speriamo
quindi così riuscirà a vedersi
background è anche una sorta di tema
natalizio se ci mettono un po di più a
darmi la partner
arriviamo a quest'estate che c'è ancora
il background natalizio quindi non
volevo farlo vedere prima prima che
passasse del tutto il natale anche se
ormai ha già passato da più di una
settimana quindi ciao arrivederci
però
lo lascerò comunque per qualche giorno
quando mi arriva la parte ha così almeno
non è stato tutto lavoro a caso mi avete
consigliato anche bunnymen che mi sembra
abbastanza interessante questo è sempre
oro e quindi cercherò di distribuirlo
più in là perché non voglio fare
ovviamente torniamo su risorse di prima
non voglio fare soltanto video horror e
niente dovrei avevi detto tutto era un
blog veloce giusto per dirvi i futuri vi
dei progetti
sto mettendo circa un video al giorno
con cupido ogni due giorni minimo perché
a me l'avete chiesto in tanti anche se
ci metto tanto a farli ad evitarli però
per accontentarvi lo faccio anche
soprattutto anche per il fatto che la
mia scuola è veramente difficile quindi
mi occupa un casino di tempo potevo
farlo nelle vacanze
però adesso difficile comunque cercherò
di fare dimettere più video possibili
diciamo arriverò anke a uno ogni due
giorni se se volete se riesco a farli
soprattutto quindi niente sotto l'ultima
cosa che mi ero dimenticato di dire
scribblenauts che questo lolo pre
acquistato su steam e lo giocherò mi
pare 15 febbraio esce quindi giocherò
più o meno quando uscirà
ok vi ho detto tutto e non è rimasto più
niente spero perché di sicuro poi mi
dimentico 10.000 cose niente se lasciate
un commento qui sotto se avete dei
consigli lasciato mi piace sulla pagina
facebook vi ricordo se volete
partecipare a questo video a questa
serie che porterà avanti su questo
canale che si chiama draw my thing è
niente per ultima cosa diciamo mi sono
studiate un pochettino
un modo per chiudere i video diciamo un
po più in stile dato il il canale si
chiama fa vj tv perché ovviamente se lo
fa vige non lo potevo mettere perché
youtube non accettava erano troppo corto
dato che diciamo afa vj tv tra
virgolette televisione ho deciso di
chiudere mi vedo così